>> Alright, what do you got?
>> Who me?
>> Yeah. So, for each one, tell me whether or not it's infinite.
>> Okay. Linear separators they seeming like half
planes, or lines, or, you know, depending upon dimensionality.
There are, of course, an infinite number of
these things. There are an infinite number of lines.
>> So, that, we'll check that one off.
>> So, y equals mx plus b. And, I can put any real number for m. Any real
number for b. Infinite number of those, in fact
theres not just an infinite number of those there is
alif one of those infinite numbers. We should
talk about that one day. Artificial neutral networks
are exactly the same thing, they have weights
those weights are real numbers, so even if there
were only one weight there is an infinite
number Of real numbers to chose from, so
that's also the limit. Decision trees, with discrete
inputs. I have two answers for you here Michael.
>> O, Oh!
>> Answer one is, of course, it's finite,
a, a, assuming there is only a finite number
of features. The other answer is it could be infinite if I'm allowed
to re-use features over and over again even if they're useless to reuse.
But that is sort of insane ans silly, and no one will ever
do that, so I think the, that right answer is to leave it unchecked.
>> Okay.
>> And then finally decision tree with continuous inputs. Well,
that's the same. We had a long conversation about this when
we talked about decision trees. We can keep asking questions
about them so if there's a sort of an infinite number
of questions you can ask. I can say, well, is this
feature greater than .1. And then ask is it greater than
.11. Then is it greater than .111, then .1111, then 1111111
and so on and so forth. So, that is also infinite.
>> So basically everything we've talked
about, or nearly everything we've talked
about actually doesn't fit the analysis that we talked about last time.
>> What about k and n?
>> Yeah so k and n is a little bit of a mess.
I think you and I maybe don't completely agree on this one. So
I think of k and n, the classifier that comes out of a k
and n is defined by the set of data points that are the, the neighbors.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And. There's an infinite number of ways of
laying out those points. So theres an infinite number
of different tan N base classifiers that you could
have. But you have a counter argument to that.
>> Right, which is that if you assume the training set
is fixed. And that's just part of the parameters of the hypothese
base then. It is an infinite. There's, in
fact, only one. It all just depends upon
Q. And it always gives you the same
answer, no matter what. So I think the hypothesis
space, you could argue, is finite. It all
depends upon what it is you're taking as
part of the hypothesis. And what it is
you aren't taking as part of the hypothesis space.
>> Right. Sort of, whether the data is built in
or not. But it, but it, you know? Is strikes
me that these other methods are also similar in that,
if you bake in the data, there's just the one answer.
But yeah it's a, k and n
is weird. Right? Because it's sometimes called non-parametric.
>> Right.
>> Which sounds like it should mean that it has no parameters
but what it actually means that it has an infinite number of parameters.
>> Right. By the way, I don't think that's true about baking
things in. So, for example, if I give you a set of data.
There's still an infinite number of
neuro-networks that are consistent with that data.
There's a whole bunch of decision trees that are consistent with that data.
So you don't always get the same answer every time. Certainly
with neuro-networks you don't because you're starting at a random place.
>> But it, but if you, right. If you're
bake in the algorithm and the data and I think
in k and n that is exactly what you're doing.
But I agree that we can agree to not agree.
>> Agreed.